all right uh let's answer a couple
questions or at least one httr 94 on
twitter is there anything washington can
do to trade for a top quarterback
like desean watson or russell wilson or
will they have to settle for sam darnold
or marcus mariota
hey shireen yeah you can offer chase
young and terry mclaren
plus a couple of first-round picks that
would probably get you
deshawn watson or russell wilson if you
want to give up chase young
and terry mclaurin yeah no doubt
if i'm one of those teams i absolutely
settle for that if i've decided that i
have to trade my quarterback
yes absolutely i and and if i'm houston
or seattle and i decide that i would i
would take those guys
and if i'm washington certainly i would
give them up to get one of those
top-tier quarterbacks i know chase young
looks special
but but i would definitely do it on
either side mike
yeah so it's doable but you may have to
give up more than you want to give up in
order to get the guy one more real
quickly before we break vamos for ramos
how can the salary cap go down if teams
are playing one extra game
this year is everyone essentially
playing one uncompensated game in 2021
the answer to that is no they're not
the salary cap this year is driven by
all the money that was lost
last year salaries didn't go down last
year as the nfl teams were losing money
the reduced revenue due to what was it
about 1.2 million fans instead of 17
million fans
that affects this year's cap and they've
they've agreed that it'll be no less
than 180 million
could have been a lot less you know
somebody told me last week if the nflpa
and the nfl hadn't worked out their deal
last year if they had been in the last
year their most recent cba
the salary cap this year would have been
160. so
there's an extra 20 million there
because they did that deal last year in
march and again
in july to allow the season to go
forward in a pandemic
but that that's all it is and the extra
game helps it helps tremendously
for next year it's not going to help
much for this year
yeah mike and and players knew this
going into this year
that with no fans that revenues were
going to go down and
and how things were going to be with the
sour cap this year we're just on the
fringe now of some veterans getting cut
there's going to be a lot more to come
mike over the next week before free
agency starts
i you know it occurred to me earlier
today and i don't want to do this i
don't want to put it out as a poll
question and i'm not going to
but i have a feeling there's going to
because i just don't think it's right to
speculate on who's going to lose their
job
like as a sport but i think that that
there's going to be at least one name
that we're going to say
holy sheep i had no idea
that was coming hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports